i thought about this some more i think
what i'm saying michael smith
is that michael jordan
look it's like aesthetically
michael aesthetically michael jordan is
the perfect basketball player
aesthetically i mean the perfect height
you know six six def
uh well defined just look everything
looks easy nothing
even the rugged michael jordan play the
post up looks smooth
nothing looks like it's it's it's hard
work for him
he was working hard even me sweating he
never looked like he was working that
hard
so aesthetically he's perfect as a
basketball player artistic
but lebron james can do more things
than michael jordan and i know we're
nitpicking because we're talking about
like what the rarest the
the rarest the rarest of talents like do
more
like what play more positions and play
more positions he can he can affect
he can affect more places on the court
than michael jordan can and i thought
about this when you said yesterday
jordan was a better scorer
if you look at the all-time numbers it's
right there i don't know i'm going to
get into lebron averages this
jordan averages that that's not where
i'm going if you look at the all-time
numbers
yep lebron has numbers for a guy
who is not focused on scoring right but
not even
his scoring numbers are off the charts
whereas a guy we're scoring was
important to him
that was part of his identity it was not
like hey i'll just do anything to win a
game no michael jordan was not that
he'll tell you that he wasn't that i'll
do anything but if it means yeah
but he was god yeah but he scored
he scored what he needed to score he
could i mean he didn't score all he
could have scored
if he was just about scoring and not
winning i think i think but no i agree
with you on lebron
scoring was number one for his player it
was primary for him
no i think respectfully winning was
primary for him
scoring in the process yeah yeah okay
winning is
lebron's a pass first player who happens
to average what 28 a game for his career
27 game per square
something craziness for for mike avery
you're 100 right
you're 100 right mike average 30 round
and nose so i would say
um it's just the ability to do multiple
things but this is where
you can get you can slap me around here
because
i'm inconsistent because i thought about
your
your stevie wonder prince thing
you're like hey it's just preference and
based on what i'm saying i should
be more into prince than i am
into stevie because prince
can do more things than stevie
right i mean just by nature of just by
virtue of playing all these positions
okay right oh yeah one guy
yeah okay okay okay yeah i hear you that
wasn't that wasn't how i intended the
analogy but yeah if you wanted to apply
it literally
yeah okay i hear you i know you didn't
you you were standing up what you're
putting down
it's greatness it's greatness you're
good yeah no wrong answer
yeah and when i'm giving you why i think
lebron is
better than jordan if i apply that logic
to basketball
if i like apply that logic to music yeah
between prince and stevie wonder both
multi-talented
extremely versatile songwriters i didn't
know
i didn't know you were a stevie guy so
over prince
i i mean i the reason i use those two
are you
because the answer what no but the
answer is yes
that's the reason i use those two
because it's like i mean i'm sorry i
guess i assume for me
you're not gonna get me to say that
prince or stevie is better than the
other
in terms of their musical genius um
which is why
i i i likened lebron and jordan because
at this point
i'm not going to say lebron and jordan
like that too i'm not going to argue you
down if you say
that you think lebron is better i
personally prefer
michael jordan i guess and i know we
over time and we got a lot to cover
today so i don't want to
just what is time but a construct what
is time really
i i could not agree more but we on that
three and off at five
uh so when did you come to this
conclusion though
that's what i'm wondering like what is
it because oh is there some recency bias
here because i think michael jordan
is underrated in 2021 let me say that
again i think michael jordan is
underrated in 2021 because as time
passed people like you like to reduce
his game to scoring
and championships michael jordan is like
he scored a bunch of points and he went
six for six in the finals
not that he's one of all time greatest
defenders not that nobody ever had a
better back to the basket or post game
nothing there's never been a more
skilled basketball player a competitive
basketball player not that he was a
brilliant
passer in his own right it just seemed
to score any one championships
brilliant yes he was okay damn it yes he
was i will send you videos no i don't
remember that since you can't i don't
know exactly
that's right since all you kids do is
watching youtube
a youtube video it's called the packet
as a matter of fact watch
michael jordan the puppeteer google it
okay you know your kids like
but he's underrated in terms of the
totality he's not underrated because
you're wearing that man's shoes right
now
it ain't about he ain't underrated no no
no
mars it is not about the shoes it is
about about that
no but i'm saying michael jordan
is the only guy his age he's the only
basketball player
his age who is even holding his own in
these conversations and winning these
conversations
most guys in their 50s when you talk
about players contemporary players
most guys you know in their 50s lose
that argument they're like what
no no
no right what you said yesterday sorry
but i do want to
kind of close this up before we go to
break what you said yesterday though
where you started which i i agreed now i
understood you talked about the
nostalgia
attached to michael jordan by people
from our generation and
i get that i totally get that and that
may be creating a blind spot when it
comes to lebron james
conversely what i want to know from you
as
gary plays the music maybe you can
answer it or maybe we figured out
another side it's like
is it because of the longevity that
lebron is displaying
and how he continues to be brilliant
this late in this career he's like
what switch what switch to flip this
switch for you what switched your
perspective
something that lebron did recently makes
him better than he was a year ago
two years ago hell two weeks ago what
changed this for you
is is what my kind of car
as usual you have asked a fantastic
question
i'm gonna answer it i'm gonna answer it
right now it's an easy answer
we talked about the longevity right
it's longevity of the pandemic it's the
pandemic
this thing is going on too much
i don't mind the devil's workshop they
say hey thanks for watching brother from
another on youtube
make sure you hit subscribe before you
leave and be sure to watch us
three to five p.m eastern time on
peacock
appreciate you